yes a neodymium is one of my favorite
elements to work with when you use it in
compounds and you dissolve it often you
get beautiful blue solutions from it
sometimes they're green as well but
often I found it if the concentration of
the solution makes a really big
difference to the color of these
solutions so you may have a compound
which appears to be red but actually as
you dilute it down eventually ends up
being blue which is really pretty and
sometimes if you cannula it from one
class to another and you can see through
the candle you can see it changing color
as it goes through the cannula and then
drops into the next solution again so
neodymium is one of the rare earths and
it has a number of quite important
applications one of the my favorite is
in lasers it's used for example in this
laser pointer and if you point the laser
it makes this rather nice bright green
color a little known use of neodymium is
that the size and strength of volcanic
eruptions can actually be judged from
the composition of neodymium isotopes
which are present the first laser
pointers were red they didn't use
neodymium and the green ones have become
really quite fashionable but among
lecturers so the way this works is the
inside here there is a small crystal of
so called neodymium YAG these are some
of the neodymium atoms that are isolated
in the glass that contains yttrium
and aluminium together to form so called
the G is for garnet which describes the
structure of the solid and if you excite
this the neodymium atoms can emit light
in the infrared like heat rays you can't
see them and then further up here there
is another crystal which turns this
infrared light into green light so the
green light comes out at the end and
also where neodymium is combined with
iron and boron it can form a type of
magnet which we call a permanent magnet
and it is extremely strong one of the
strongest that we actually know of in
order to get this doubling from the
infrared to the green to work you need
to have
of light so green lasers although to the
eye look as if they're continuous are
actually very rapid pulses which are
very intense which is why these pointers
are quite dangerous if you put point in
the wrong direction in the lecture and
because I wave my hands so much I never
use these in in lectures but I know that
you the cameraman have also used used
neodymium because neodymium is element
number 60 and the camera man's future
mother-in-law was sixty a few days ago
and so we provided a sample of neodymium
element 60 for him to present to her as
a birthday present happy birthday Marion